-Hey, David. How are you?
-I'm good. How are you, Seth
-I'm doing very well.
Congrats on your new show.
I'm very jealous.
I feel like for a long time,
my dream was to shoot a comedy
in England,
and that's exactly
what you got to do.
-Yeah. I feel really,
really blessed, actually.
It's a lot of fun
to work in -- in the U.K.
-And you -- Did you know
the creator of this show?
How did you get involved
in the first place?
-Yeah, he's a buddy of mine,
Nick Mohammed.
You know, he and this othe
writer and actor, Julia Davis,
had created a show
that they were thinking abou
adding an American character to.
This was a couple years ago.
So I went out to London to d
about a week of improv with them
and just kind of
find that character
and find who this guy would be
We discovered a really fun
dynamic between Nick and I
of kind of a difference
in status and power.
And I guess Nick
really loved that dynamic.
And we had such a good tim
working together
that about a year later,
he just e-mailed me this idea.
And I just thought it was --
I was just so tickled
by the idea of a workplace
comedy
set in the high-stakes world
of national security
and cyber terrorism that I -
and this guy who's such
a pompous American blowhard.
I just thought it was a really
fun opportunity, so...
-It does seem like a character
that you sink your teeth into.
Did you know from the earl
creation of the character
or the fact that it was this
workplace intelligence comed
that you wanted to be the bras
sort of blowhardy
American character?
-That's kind of who he was
from the offset.
And we worked on it then
together for about a year,
year and a half, trying to
find -- trying to find this guy,
who, to me, is inspired from
a lot of men in power in our -
-Yeah.
-In our country
and probably his,
this, you know --
This mostly ignorant narcissis
and casually -- casually sexis
and racist and homophobic
and -- and very patriotic,
mostly because
he's never been out of
the United States in his life.
-[ Chuckling ] Right.
Were you --
You know, obviously, we both
have backgrounds as improvisers,
but I haven't done it
for so long.
I think I would be
a little terrified
if somebody said, "Hey,
let's go -- Let's improvise.
Did you -- Was it all --
Did it all come back to you,
or was it scary?
-It was -- It wasn't scary
but I -- You know, I --
I know your background of improv
and Boom Chicago and everything.
But, you know,
I learned early on
from when I was in
an improv group with Colbert
that I --
He just outclassed me, you know?
So, I-I kind of approach i
when I'm in --
I think it's a little --
I approach it more like
an actor in character.
As long as I've got
a really solid character
and kind of an idea
of what the scene's about,
I feel permission to improv.
And Nick is so good.
He's as good as you
and Colbert at it.
So I feel like he carried me
pretty much, so...
-You -- So, you brought up
Colbert. Now I need to say it.
Colbert, you, myself, our othe
guest tonight, Robin Thede
all graduates of
Northwestern University.
-I know we've talked
about it before.
You spoke at my graduation
And I know that's like --
There's a good and bad to that
'cause, one, I feel like
I'm -- I'm age-shaming you
But two, you gave...
-You are. You are.
Thank you for that. Thanks
-...the best commencement speech
I've ever -- I mean,
I haven't heard that many,
but it was outstanding.
-Well, thank you.
-And then -- So right out
of college, did you --
I know Lookingglass was your
theater company in Chicago
Was that right out of colleg
that you started that?
-Yeah, we started upon
graduation, actually,
from Northwestern, maybe because
we just didn't want --
We were too scared
to enter the real world.
But, yeah, we --
We really were hungry
and determined
to start our own company.
We had been directing
each other in --
throughout, you know,
our years at Northwestern.
And then I started
to bounce back
between auditioning
for TV and film in L.A.
and commuting to Chicago.
So I'd go back and forth
to do theater in Chicago
with my company and try to -
try to climb
the, you know, the Hollywood
you know, rungs, as it were,
the ladder, to try to eke out
career in TV and film, as well
-It's funny. You know,
obviously, you know, I think
like everybody in that cast, you
came to prominence on "Friends."
I did not realize that you wer
on another iconic show.
I did not realize till today
that you were on
"The Wonder Years."
-Oh, yeah.
-And based on this photo, a very
different character than Ross.
-I was playing this -- this kind
of hippie -- not hippie,
but more like a wandering
construction kind of guy and -
who fell in love
with Olivia Dabo's character
you know, the sister.
And that was my first
introduction to TV, really
I mean, that was
my first real break.
And I can tell you, the first --
Actually, my first real scen
on-camera --
You know, I come from theater,
so I had no idea
what I was doing, right?
I just thought, "Okay, we al
rehearse this big dinner scene."
Actually, about five of us
sat at the table.
And we rehearsed,
and I felt kind of nervous
I'm stepping into this big cast,
this huge show.
And they shoot --
They shoot Fred first.
They shoot him 'cause he had t
go to school after his --
-[ Laughs ] Right, of course
-So, they shot him out.
And then they shoot
everyone else out, and I'm last.
And when I'm finally on-camera
I'm acting across
a piece of tape
that they put
next to the camera box
and some older script supervisor
kind of reading the lines.
And I'm like, "Oh, my God.
This is my intro --
I'm just acting
with a piece of tape."
Anyway, it was -- It was baptism
by fire, I guess, but, you know.
-I think the other weird thing
that happens
is the first time
you're on television --
My first time, I was --
had a very small role
in an episode of "Spin City.
People at home, they see you
and they assume,
since you've been
on network television,
that you have now made it,
and you have nothing but money
But the reality is, like,
as soon as I did that episode,
I went back to my normal life.
And the same happened
for you, right?
-For sure. I mean, I was
waiting tables for seven years
during all these little gigs
you know?
You're right.
I mean, people think,
"Wow, you're on TV.
You made it!"
But, I mean, the first tim
I actually saw myself
on television,
on "The Wonder Years,"
I was waiting tables --
I was on my shift.
And one of my buddies,
another waiter, you know,
pointed out to the televisio
that we had over the bar -
at the bar area
of the restaurant.
He said, "Schwimmer,
you're on TV."
You know, and I turn,
and I looked. I'm like, "Yeah.
Then I turn back to my table
I was like, "Do you want
blue cheese or thousand island?"
-[ Laughs ]
It's very humbling.
It's -- That's a good story.
I hope that everybody who'
trying to get into this business
can hear that
and be a little inspired
by how it ultimately turned out.
-Well, it also -- I think
it teaches you so much respect
for anyone
in the service industry,
for the rest of your life.
I mean, if you've ever
waited tables,
as I did for seven years,
first of all,
you tip really well
for the rest of your life...
-Absolutely.
-...because you just know
how much -- how much
people rely on gratuity.
And that's the only way
I paid my bills,
you know, for all those years.
-I also -- I don't know
if you feel this way,
but I think there's
this projection
of how stressful
show business can be.
And it's not
without its stresses,
but the only stress dreams
I ever have
are ones about being a waiter.
Like, that is still --
That, like, table seven
needs their burrito.
That will wake me up
in the middle of the night
more than anything
that ever happened in my career.
Well, I hope,
one, that we can --
all of us can get back
to restaurants soon.
And, two,
that we all can remember
to over-tip our wait staff
-Yes, yes.
-And congrats on the show.
It's always so nice
talking to you, David.
-Thanks, man. Thank, Seth.
I appreciate it.